um so to all of you Barbie has had many
jobs as a represented in our audience
today
um lawyer doctor everything so what were
all of your first paid jobs
oh also I'm going to start with the Sigh
okay
I was saying um I was a little League
umpire
oh
should have checked the rules before
doing that gig because man who those
parents on this side and on this side
what what and I'm like I don't was it a
ball was it a strike what is the
difference and
can she be running now I don't know um
she's out
is she out I don't know I'm sorry oh my
God they just let anybody do it right
how did you get this job no I I think I
said I knew the room and I I did on some
level they were there somewhere and um
it didn't go so that's like fired you
were fired from my um well that's
shocking
find someone that knows you were an
actor before you're an actor you know
how actors are always lying on your
resume I can totally ride a horse I'm
Jolene equestrian I'm totally this you
were just ahead of your game um America
what about you what was your first paid
job the first job I got paid to do that
wasn't like an official job was my next
door neighbor had a very big pop belly
pig
and I got paid to clean up after the
pick yeah that's what I did all right
yeah making money at a young age I like
it I was a hustler you know I would take
it where I could get it absolutely what
about you Isa um similar I had a
neighbor who
um needed her cat's babysat that rhymes
um and I did that at like eight but then
I discovered that I was allergic so I
had to quit the next day
I found out I was allergic the hard way
too I rescued one and I was like what is
happening I just couldn't get it
together and you're like we were highly
allergic to cats was like super episode
I found her a home me too I love cats I
can't mess with them no more than dogs
because I'm right um but anyway
I'm just kidding but not
um so what about you what was like your
first paid job I had I started as a
hustler too I started young I was
working in a restaurant when I started
when I was 10 working in like the back
in the kitchen but um my hustle started
earlier than that I used to actually my
way of making money before I was working
at a restaurant
um I would steal my brother's toys and
then sell them out on the street
I know and he'd get so mad where's my
truck feeling and I was like I got two
bucks for it
can I have some of the money I was like
nope
that wasn't your store out on the street
that was my store so as a producer on
this what do you what do you hope people
take away like the messaging
I think I mean first of all it's so fun
I mean when you see these sets it's like
a dopamine hit like you just yeah are so
happy and the movie is so funny it's
also kind of unexpectedly emotional I I
have to say and
it's weird I didn't think I would do a
Barbie movie and have so many
conversations about the meaning of life
with you know behind the scenes you know
like because when we're talking about
okay so life is perfect like if this is
the Utopia what's the perfect ending
what's the what's the version of what
what is happiness what is life is all
these questions came up that we were
trying to answer so that we could kind
of round up this movie the way you know
it needed to be and it you get you end
up having these incredibly profound
conversations about life and what's
important and what makes really true
happiness and that is all woven into the
movie and there are quite like you'll
find moments where you're like wow that
really hit me in like a profound
emotional way and overall it's just it's
hysterical and it's funny it's a bunch
of adults acting like having tantrums
and being children sometimes so and it's
a beautifully designed world it's just
oh my gosh I think people are just gonna
really be happy and have so much fun we
had a whole Miniatures Workshop you
could go like that hand paint tiny
flamingos like this that then I'd go and
set and there'd be a Flamingo mailbox
that life size I mean everything was you
know the painted backdrops the the dream
houses that we were actually you know
going down the slide to the pool and all
that stuff there was so much in camera
kind of trickery which is very
satisfying and it gives you that
tangible feel like yeah Greta said from
the start yeah because he just jumped
into the world feel like they can reach
in and grab everything because that
would that's the world of play with
Barbies and stuff so yeah it's really
beautifully crafted
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]